oddly the people who are most
woke and who used the term privileged in
that pejorative sense which means you
have to shut the up
they are overwhelmingly
white
affluent and well-educated in other
words they are the privileged yeah yeah
right it's the privilege
who are telling other white people to
shut the up and the irony of this
self-selected Elite is that they're
getting down on everyone else for being
privileged
but what they really want is more
privilege for themselves it is a kind of
greed because on top of having all the
money and the great education
and all the status that's not enough for
them they have to have the moral High
Ground yeah
[Applause]